Three-dimensional case.
Now, in the future
homework, you will
be doing the equivalent
of this calculation
here with the Laplacians--
it's not complicated--
so that you will
derive with the current is.
And the current must be a very
similar formula as this one.
And indeed, I'll
just write it here.
The current is h bar over m,
the imaginary part of psi star.
And instead of ddx, you
expect the gradient of psi.
That is the current
for the probability
in three dimensions.
And the analog of this equation,
d rho dt plus dj dx equals 0,
is d rho dt plus divergence
of j is equal to 0.
That is current conservation.
Perhaps you do remember
that from your study
of electromagnetism.
That's how Maxwell discovered
the displacement current
when he tried to figure
out how everything
was compatible with
current conservation.
Anyway, that argument
I'll do in a second
so that it will become clearer.
So one last thing here--
it's something also-- you
can check the units here of j
is 1 over l squared times 1 over
t, so probability per unit area
and unit time.
So what did we have?
We were doing the integral of
the derivative of the integral
given by n.
It was over here, dn dt.
We worked hard on it.
And dn dt was the
integral of d rho dt.
So it was the integral
of d rho dt dx.
But we showed now that
d rho dt is minus dj dx.
So here you have integral
from minus infinity
to infinity dx of dj dx.
And therefore, this is--
I should have a minus sign,
because it was minus dj dx.
This is minus the current
of x equals infinity times
p minus the current at x
equals minus infinity nt.
And as we more or
less hinted before,
since the current is equal to
h over 2im psi star [INAUDIBLE]
psi dx minus psi [INAUDIBLE]
psi star dx, as you
go to plus infinity
or minus infinity,
these things go to
0 given the boundary
conditions that we put.
Because psi or psi star
go to 0 to infinity,
and the derivates are
bound at the infinity.
So this is 0, dn dt 0.
All is good.
And two things happened.
In the way of doing
this, we realized
that the computation we
have done pretty much
established that this is equal
to that, because dn dt is
the difference of
these two integrals,
and we showed it's 0.
So this is true.
And therefore, we suspect
h is a Hermitian operator.
And the thing that we should
do in order to make sure it is
is put two different functions
here, not two equal functions.
This worked for
two equal function,
but for two different
functions, and check it as well.
And we'll leave
it as an exercise.
It's a good exercise.
So this shows the consistency.
But we discover two
important ideas--
one, the existence of a current
for probability, and two,
h is a Hermitian operator.
So last thing is to
explain the analogy
with current conservation.
I think this should
help as well.
So the interpretation
that we'll have
is the same as we have
in electromagnetism.
And there's a complete
analogy for everything here.
So not for the wave function,
but for all these charge
densities and current densities.
So we have electromagnetism
and quantum mechanics.
We have rho.
Here is the charge density.
And here is the
probability density.
If you have a total
charge q in a volume,
here is the probability to
find the particle in a volume.
There is a j in Maxwell's
equations as well,
and that's a current density.
Amber's law has that current.
It generates the curl of b.
And here is a probability
current density.
So that's the table.
So what I want to make
sure is that you understand
why these equations,
like this or that,
are more powerful than just
showing that dn dt is 0.
They imply a local
conservation of probability.
You see, there has to be
physics of this thing.
So the total
probability must be 1.
But suppose you have the
probability distributed
over space.
There must be some
relation between the way
the probabilities are varying
at one point and varying
in other points so that
everything is consistent.
And those are these
differential relations
that say that whenever you
see a probability density
change anywhere, it's because
there is some current.
And that makes sense.
If you see the charge density
in some point in space changing,
it's because there
must be a current.
So thanks to the
current, you can
learn how to interpret
the probability much more
physically.
Because if you ask what is the
probability that the particle
is from this distance
to that distance,
you can look at what the
currents are at the edges
and see whether that probability
is increasing or decreasing.
So let's see that.
Suppose you have a
volume, and define
the charge inside the volume.
Then you say OK, does this
charge change in time?
Sure, it could.
So dq dt is equal
to integral d rho dt
d cube x over the volume.
But d rho dt, by the current
conservation equation--
that's the equation
we're trying to make sure
your intuition is clear about--
this is equal to minus
the integral of j--
no, of divergence of j d
cube x over the volume.
OK.
But then Gauss's law.
Gauss's Lot tells you that
you can relate this divergence
to a surface integral.
dq dt is therefore minus
the surface integral,
the area of the
current times that.
So I'll write it as minus
jda, the flux of the current,
over the surface that bounds--
this is the volume, and there's
the surface bounding it.
So by the divergence
theorem, it becomes this.
And this is how you understand
current conservation.
You say, look, charge is
never created or destroyed.
So if you see the charge
inside the volume changing,
it's because there's
some current escaping
through the surface.
So that's the physical
interpretation
of that differential equation,
of that d rho dt plus
divergence of j is equal to 0.
This is current conservation.
And many people look at
this equation and say, what?
Current conservation?
I don't see anything.
But when you look at this
equation, you say, oh, yes.
The charge changes only because
it escapes the volume, not
created nor destroyed.
So the same thing happens
for the probability.
Now, let me close up
with this statement
in one dimension, which is the
one you care, at this moment.
And on the line, you
would have points a and b.
And you would say
the probability
to be within a and b is the
integral from a to b dx of rho.
That's your probability.
That's the integral of
psi squared from a to b.
Now, what is the time
derivative of it?
dp ab dt would be integral
from a to b dx of d rho dt.
But again, for that case,
d rho dt is minus dj dx.
So this is minus dx
dj dx between b and a.
And what is that?
Well, you get the
j at the boundary.
So this is minus j at x equals
bt minus j at x equal a, t.
So simplifying it,
you get dp ab dt
is equal to minus j at x
equals bt plus j of a, t.
Let's see if that makes sense.
You have been looking
for the particle
and decided to look at
this range from a to b.
That's the probability
to find it there.
We learned already that
the total probability
to find it anywhere
is going to be 1,
and that's going
to be conserved,
and it's going to
be no problems.
But now let's just
ask given what happens
to this probability in time.
Well, it could change,
because the wave
function could go up and down.
Maybe the wave
function was big here
and a little later is small
so there's less probability
to find it here.
But now you have another
physical variable
to help you understand it,
and that's the current.
That formula we found
there for j of x and t
in the upper
blackboard box formula
is a current that
can be computed.
And here you see
if the probability
to find the particle
in this region changes,
it's because some current must
be escaping from the edges.
And let's see if the
formula gives it right.
Well, we're assuming
quantities are
positive if they
have plus components
in the direction of x.
So this current is the current
component in the x direction.
And it should not
be lost-- maybe
I didn't quite say it--
that if you are dealing
with a divergence of j, this
is dj x dx plus dj y dy plus dj
z dz.
And in the case of one
dimension, you will have those,
and you get this equation.
So it's certainly the reduction.
But here you see indeed,
if the currents are
positive-- if the
current at b is positive,
there is a current going out.
So that tends to
reduce the probability.
That's why the sign
came out with a minus.
On the other hand, if
there is a current in a,
that tends to send
in probability,
and that's why it
increases it here.
So the difference between
these two currents
determines whether
the probability here
increases or decreases.